name foods that go with peanut butter i
don't have that i have nothing i have
bread chicken
chicken is not all right no we're done
we're done
all right the last few answers
butter chicken
that's not what is
that's not what it means
that's not what butter chicken means
[Music]
this shit's stupid look at his face this
is stupid and guess what
it was
hey you know what it was dumber
what not having bread yeah
that was stupid thank you okay
go ahead i didn't bat an eyelash because
i've had straight up chicken with peanut
butter and it's pretty dope yeah i feel
like that's a thing somewhere in america
100
you're looking at me like steve harvey
no i'm dead serious there's 100
people who eat chicken with peanut
butter i'm pretty sure
i actually want to try peanut sauce
smoke weed i used to and that's when
that's the exact time actually
the peak of my wheat smoke
it really sounds like a
munchies
oh
i know what we gonna do what
chicken and peanut butter
cause i had chicken right and then i
always love peanut sauce bro
what you saying okay cause you know what
happened i had chicken right wrong
it doesn't make it right dude
don't knock it till you try it that's
all i'm saying